I've always tried to follow some thing as opposed to thinking of his training.
Even that,
even the word training tastes like homework,
right.
So I've always tried to,
I was running for a long period of time.
She's about seven years.
When I jogged and ran and I decided on the road,
I'll run across every bridge in America that we toured the root.
So I probably 1520 different bridges,
Golden Gate Brooklyn.
And that's where I rent.
No,
I did smoke a joint and run the New York City Marathon
and I came in and right behind the wheelchairs in the back.
Okay,
well some folks need the ribbon and they need to see the clock and everybody
clapping.
And then there's some folks you know who just just wondering.
You did okay.
And they had took down the clock,
but the line was still there on the scene meant in central park,
hopped over the line,
got the picture airborne,
went home,
took a nap.
And that night I went out and got drunk on Tequila.
How long did it take you to finish the marathon?
About five and a half hour.
So that's not bad.
That's very good.
It's better than Berg question.
Now let's come on.
Let's be complimentary.
It's the worst.
It's definitely,
yes.
That's about the absolute worst that it was the winter.
Do It our 20,
I think they get it in around two hours.
Like two hours in seven seconds.
I think they're trying to break two hours.
Isn't that what's going on?
Yeah.
Someone's trying to break two hours.
So,
but that's what I did for a,
a period of time,
you know,
keep going,
kayaking,
you know,
so you just always been involved in physical activities that were fun in the
early nineties kayaking was illegal in Manhattan.
Okay.
Because it was dirty water and people would get trundled over under the ferry
boats.
Oh God.
So what we did is we cut a hole in the fence next to the 14th street sanitation
department over by the,
uh,
west side highway.
Y'All know what I'm talking about?
If you're from there.
And we did it exactly like movie style,
like a greatest scape where we fitted the fence back with duck tape and we would
drag our kayaks from union square west all the way down 14th street.
Okay.
And you pick up your provisions for it.
All right?
You got to get a your bagels.
She gotta get shit.
So what,
you know like this,
you got to get something to drink,
get some Gatorade,
you know,
not to drink the gate arrays.
So you have something to Wiz in serious.
And we'd get the girlfriends.
Okay.
To wait up is in the meatpacking district right there.
It's dead silent.
It was a ghost town then there was not hip hop.
It was not going,
which is what it's doing now.
And he'd go to shopping with,
your old lady had said Stella Mccartney down there now at Benton is a ghost
town.
That it was great,
scary,
dangerous.
And one girlfriend,
which I gotta be careful of names,
they're all married now.
How'd you manage it?
Mine.
Karen
would always go north and wait around because if the cops come,
they would step out.
We would see them.
And whatever,
and we would sneak our bolts through the hole in the fence into the river,
right,
where solely landed his plane right there.
All right.
And then girls would come at jumping to boats and we would take off more than
two or three times.
Local PD would show going,
hey,
what do,
what?
Are you going to touch that water back then?
No,
that was,
that was death.
Inky black whore or death like this.
Did you have a Dunkin it accidentally?
No,
not in,
not in that river particular,
but we started a number of the trips today.
There's probably six different kayak clubs that you can jump.
Manhattan Kayak Club and Brooklyn clock.
Many,
many.
Now the boomers with senses of humor figured it all out.
All right.
And we would go,
Geez,
we started,
Trish would go at midnight under the Verrazano Bridge in the winter.
All right.
And you were dry shoots or something.
You know,
you're a long,
a long Johns inside of a dry sheet like this.
And don't get me wrong,
I would be the DJ,
I have a,
um,
a a tape player and I would bungee to take player like this and everybody would
have,
this is a primitive times know it's 19,
early nineties.
You know,
I just,
and we would have a little little microphones in the earpieces that you use on
motorcycles back then.
So you have communications from boat to boat.
Oh Wow.
And I would put mine on the tape player and I'd be the Tj.
Oh yeah.
And we'd listen to the ball game late at night sometimes,
you know,
and you'd hear laughing all,
you couldn't see anybody in the swells.
And we go under the same bridge that John Travolta sits and looks at with the
girlfriend in Saturday night fever,
same bridge.
And know that a woody Allen in Manhattan,
it looks at,
you know,
you have a wonderful listen on the other size,
terrible imitation of either of them.
And we'd float under their full moon,
midnight February,
snow drifting like this.
And since it was illegal to do it.
We had a buddy who owned a plumbing company in Brooklyn and he would bring his
truck and park it right off a Coney island.
You're still well having avenue where the Ferris wheel is and he would blink his
lights,
allied forces style blink,
blink like that,
and we'd be about a quarter mile off having come from under the Verrazano
Bridge.
The winter,
we'd see those lights blinking.
Nowhere to turn left.
He started,
do you even want to hear this?
Yes.
Okay.
We'd have to make the left and we'd wait for this swells like can you give us
another blank?
When all was clear and jazz,
beat ass all a quarter mile of row,
row,
catch the wave,
get out of the boat.
You know,
silently drag it all the way the beach.
Okay.
Like you see in every war movie.
All right.
Otherwise just about it.
I don't know.
$200 fine or something like this.
And we would put the boats big two person kayaks into the back of the plumbing
truck and onto the top of it,
drive it back to the coffee shop on Union Square West.
It's very well known like that and get drunk with pretty girls and tell them
about adventure stories.
And all this was going on while you were,
you were air quotes David Lee Roth.
I mean,
this is the nineties.
You were fucking huge.
You're still a rock star and you're going through polluted water in a fucking
Kayak,
hide from the cops with a tape player and uh,
and uh,
some sort of jury rigged,
uh,
microphones.
So some of the best places that I went rock climbing,
uh,
we're on walls of hotels in Europe.
We'd toss,
toss a rope out the third floor of a bed and breakfast in San Sebastian in
Spain.
That's covered from flagstone with flagstone from the 14 hundreds like that.
And then Yo,
Yo,
you know,
one guy would stay up,
watch TV and work the ballet and you can climb up the outside.
You know,
it's Jesus Christ,
hardcore jollies.
So when you were doing this all around the same time?
Oh yeah.
When my bicycles with me,
I'm an outdoors is in the blood.
You know,
it's part of growing up without any real things.
My Dad was a student,
so,
uh,
take this stick for you.
It'll be a bow for me.
It'll be a baton.